so let's switch gears almost entirely
from the snow to pool season Las Vegas's
pool season starts almost basically now
here the beginning of March just for the
traditional the pool clubs are opening
next week yeah Circus Circus meanwhile
is getting a jump start on that so it
has revamped its pool there but that's
not the only thing keeping kids and you
entertain Lauren negretti joining us
live with some of the renovations and
she's in her teacup ladies and gentlemen
are you gonna spin
yes we are I figured we'd start off
stagnant like just stable at first and
then we'll get it going towards the
middle here but she's jumping ahead
there Heather for right now like I'm
here with Shayna Garrity VP of senior
vice president operations talking about
all this new stuff we're in one of them
so we got four new rides super exciting
teacups nebula it's a swing set uh tell
us about all this stuff going on here we
do we have four brand new rides that are
here we have nebula Z that goes forwards
and backwards and a little bit of
excitement for everybody on that one
um your typical swings as well you would
be surprised at the number of adults
that find pure enjoyment in writing
those also
um The Teacup obviously that we're
sitting in which I don't think anyone
can ever go go wrong doing that and then
we do have our
little Sprinter Raceway that is for
little kids only and they are a blast to
watch so we have 28 rides under five
five acres here and we have we're
sitting in one of the brand new ones
let's get it going on that part let's
let's get this going here but yeah uh uh
this one is open for all Heights nebula
Z you got to be over 42 inches that was
a parole Heights Here We Go
again all of this it's 30 bucks if you
are under four feet 48 inches 60 bucks
if you're over for now live in a teacup
Laurie Grady eight news now back to you
guys you can still see me she's at all
Heights so we can get in the teacups
we're good we're good
[Laughter]
you know yeah they actually they move
pretty fast I'm more bye Lauren things a
little faster to teacup thanks though
appreciate it